i'm just taking it as it comes every
week with something new
and i'm just taking it rihanna is taking
all the headline-making drama she and
boyfriend asap rocky have been
experiencing in the past few weeks in
stride
following the rapper's recent arrest and
cheating rumors a source tells e.t quote
there was no question or hesitation that
rihanna would stand by asap rocky when
she's in love with someone she'll do
anything for them
the source adds quote it's been a rocky
couple of weeks no pun intended first
with the cheating rumors and then with
the arrest but quote rihanna hasn't
wavered in her commitment and trust of
asap rocky quote she loves him he's
family what are you enjoying about this
journey with three right now everything
about it
i'm loving it
according to a previous source the
pregnant mogul and rapper were caught
off guard when he was arrested on april
20th for assault with a deadly weapon in
connection with a november 2021 shooting
he was later released on 550 000 bill
asap's recent arrest came less than a
week after rumors started circulating
that he cheated on re with shoe designer
amina muwadi who worked on a fenty
footwear collaboration but amina shot
down those rumors with this tweet that
reads quote i've always believed that an
unfounded lie spread on social media
doesn't deserve any response or
clarification especially one that is so
vile i initially assumed that this bay
gossip fabricated with such malicious
intent would not be taken seriously
however in the last 24 hours i've been
reminded that we live in a society that
is so quick to speak on topics
regardless of factual basis and that
nothing is off limits
i'm not going to let that happen here
despite all the drama
the parents to be are still making time
for date night on saturday rihanna and
asap made their first public appearance
together since his arrest they were
spotted walking arm and arm as they made
their way to dinner at giorgio baldi in
santa monica california the rapper wore
a gray hoodie over a gray
harley-davidson shirt and gray jeans
meanwhile rihanna continued to live up
to her stellar pregnancy style
the mom-to-be was sexy chic and black
and white striped shorts with a white
button-up that she left open of course
with her baby bump on full display
she topped things off with a black
jacket and silver purse i'm trying to
enjoy it as much as i could in february
rihanna opened up to e.t about how even
when it comes to fashion she's allowing
herself to make the most out of
uncomfortable times fashion is one of my
favorite things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
[Music]
you